This is what heaven is like.
And things just got a little too real.
It's episode 38 of IMG!
Okay, so this is Katy Perry
and this is Paula Deen.
Uh-oh.
Because this is Tom Hanks and this is 50 Cent.
Coincidence? Here's a caterpillar whose
pattern resembles
little penguins.
And what if Obama was a white guy?
Crystal e-mailed me a picture
she took of a cooler lid that says
'wow, look at them jugs.'
But, onto the dessert.
"Freakgirl" makes beautiful cupcakes,
but the pun award goes to her
'Up-cakes.'
Parents can be scary,
but this picture is one of the most
terrifying I've ever seen.
Can you make sense of this
shape? What is it?
And in these next two pictures
can you find the faces?
And that's right, you guessed it,
it is now time for 99 pictures of bananas.
Enjoy them all.
Here's an artist who meticulously cuts
paper with an exacto blade to make
swirling portrait out of a single
sheet.
And here is a giraffe licking a squirrel.
How about a panda on a rocking horse?
Or face paint a famous paintings?
Warhol, Pollock, 'The Scream,'
Magritte, 'Starry Night.'
Pocky box delivers realistic South Park families
and Mario delivers
any performance-enhancing drug you want,
because now
you're swimming with portals.
Hello?
Ooohh.
Baby hands are delicious,
but after the town of Kolmanskop, Namibia was abondoned wind and sand
re-claimed the homes,
leaving these eerie desert rooms.
Also eerie are underground neutrino detectors.
Eerie and very, very large.
You can like us on Facebook to show off
your exceptional taste.
And as always,
thanks for watching.